[Music]
so I'm really happy to be here with you
sitting on the floor or standing in the
back I want to start off by asking you a
question
it's a beautiful evening it's a Saturday
night if I've got that right I'm a
little mixed up but Saturday night right
so there are lots of things we could be
doing and of all of those things you've
come here to talk about this I'm curious
to know what are the concerns issues
feelings that bring you here to this
discussion and I would like you to
reflect on that for just a moment and
see if you can boil that down to one
word and then I want you to shout out
the word and Jasper is gonna write down
these words and then he's gonna pass
that piece of paper over to me sound
good all right so what what concerns
feelings issues bring you here tonight
give me a word okay account weight all
right what what poor Jasper okay a
accountability fear privacy control
utopia dystopia I was wondering about
that manipulation intrusion interest is
that recent interest in what
exploitation
control democracy misinformation data
mining mistrust personalization
personalization paranoia like are we
paranoid or or are we realistic
self-examination commodification okay
how are we doing there Jasper I think
we've got enough okay
now here's what I want to talk about you
know this book was published in January
and I left home for what was supposed to
be three weeks on the road and I'm still
moving a lot of people are interested in
this and so I've been to a few countries
and I've been to a lot of cities and I
began the very first event back in
January asking this question of that
audience which was in Boston since then
I've been around the world still going
I've asked this question every single
night afternoon whenever the event was I
want you to hear what my other Jasper's
around the world I'm just gonna read you
a few lists from different cities okay
listen fear anxiety manipulation control
identity freedom resistance power
democracy law agency rebellion another
city fear privacy paranoia
responsibility kind of like
accountability slavery empowerment
defense democracy another city
collaboration understanding parasite
resistance revolution political
prisoners another city sovereignty
determinism anti capitalism fear
profiling resistance inequality
exploitation solutions rev
lucien democracy dignity autonomy
manipulation sound familiar
okay now here's what really interests me
about this
different people different cities
different countries they the
surveillance capitalists have one word
for us they call us users we are
experiencing a range of nuanced feelings
concerns sources of anxiety and also
things that motivate us and drive us
democracy that represent our interests
these words are a way of articulating
our budding sense of our unique social
political economic and indeed
psychological interests that we share
and we share them not only with the
people in this room but with the people
in Brussels and Paris and Boston in New
York and Los Angeles and Madrid and a
whole bunch of other places now I want
to draw a parallel here in 1833 there
was a lady who lived not far from here
her name was Harriet Martineau she was
described as a social observer if she
lived today she'd be a famous
sociologist and she wrote about British
society and one of the things that she
wrote about was admonishing the
aristocracy for the following fact
because she said that what was so stupid
about the aristocrats view of British
society was that they had one term for
everybody who wasn't an aristocrat
that was called the lower classes and
she said inside the lower classes were
included the manufacturers the tradesmen
the artisans the laborers and the
poppers everybody who wasn't one of us
was part of some big anonymous category
kind of like users so that was 1833 and
as you know the great struggle of the
19th century with the emergence and
institutionalization of industrial
capitalism was how those folks in the
so-called lower classes came to
understand their political and economic
and social and psychological interests
and it was out of that the the idea of
workers and the working class emerged
and it was out of that that the great
Titanic struggles of the 20th century
were born which were between capital and
labor but all of that began earlier in a
situation much like the one we are in
now I am NOT suggesting that we are
about to replicate the 19th or 20th
centuries I am suggesting that we are at
a moment in history when we are poised
to discover our 21st century version of
our collective interests and our 21st
century version of the kind of the forms
of collective action that we will create
that will be relevant to us in our time
in our moment in history to move this
dialogue forward in politics and in
society so that's my framing now having
said that I want to talk a little bit
about
what is surveillance capitalism and in
order to do that I want to begin with an
important distinction
the surveillance capitalists have been
at this for twenty years which is to say
only twenty years that's a good thing
it's very young so we shouldn't feel too
beleaguered too much you know to
resigned too helpless this is still a
young thing they have had 20 years of
essentially a lawless run unimpeded by
law and they have had many strategies
that have helped keep law and regulation
at bay and also that have helped keep
public resistance at bay one of those is
a very specific rhetorical strategy and
I want to illustrate it before I name it
okay so let's dial back to the year 2000
before surveillance capitalism was
invented and about four years before any
trace of it leaked into the public in
the year 2000 in the United States you
know we have a great Technical
University called Georgia Tech that's
you know science engineering and so
forth a group of data scientists and
engineers from Georgia Tech put out
their plan for what today we call a
smart home they called it the aware home
and they had all the goals for the aware
home that we have today like older folks
can age in place and be connected to
their families we can be have energy
efficiency we can have security we can
get feedback that might improve our our
our lifestyle or health and so forth
when they did the schematics for the
aware home they picture devices in the
wall computerized devices in the wall
that would send data
but the schematic they drew was of a
simple closed loop the data would go
only to the occupants of the home and it
was for the occupants to know the data
to decide who else was gonna see the
data if it was going to be shared to
figure out what the data means and if
the and if any consequences of that
meaning we're gonna be implemented in
some way it was all down to the
occupants and the scientists and
engineers wrote in their report
obviously this is very intimate data
privacy is critical so it can only go to
the occupants of the home fast forward
to the year to 2017 17 years later
University of London - very cool legal
scholars decide to do an analysis of one
smart home device the nest thermostat
nest as you may know was first purchased
by Google now it has been completely
dissolved and absorbed into Google they
decided that any moderately vigilant
consumer who installs a nest thermostat
must review a minimum of 1,000 quote
unquote privacy policies 1000 why is
that because the nest thermostat
agglomerates data in your home and it
sends that to nest aka Google but it
also sends it to other third parties
which send it to other third parties
which send it to other third parties
which send it to other third parties
almost in an infinite regress no one of
those parties takes any responsibility
for any of the other parties so your
data is out there becoming part of large
AI training sets and you don't know
what's happening to it that's a whole
other story we don't have time to go
into that but here's the thing what's
the difference between 2000 and 2017
there's one difference it's digital
technology
digital devices it's the same goals of a
smart home what's the difference the
difference is surveillance capitalism
folks right same technology different
economics so my big point here is that
the surveillance capitalists have tried
to persuade us that what we are
experiencing in their territory because
they now own and operate the Internet
what we are experiencing are the
inevitable consequences of digital
technology they want us to believe that
what they do is the only way we can have
a digital future and my whole point is
that surveillance capitalism is an
economic logic which was an invented in
a specific moment in time actually in
Google during the years of financial
emergency of the dot-com bust 2000 2001
2002 it they figured it out they
invented it they elaborated it it took
root it flourished it made a ton of
money between 2000 and 2004 and 2013
sure capitalists were threatening to
pull out between 2000 and 2004 nobody
knew what they were doing but applying
the new logic of surveillance capitalism
their revenue line increased are you
ready by three thousand five hundred and
ninety percent they discovered the
breakthrough to rapid monetization
created the surveillance dividend
raising the bar for investment in the
tech sector so that this model spread
through the tech sector and is now
spreading across the normal economy in
virtually every domain ok so what is it
it's an economic logic how does it work
I'm gonna be super crash course about
this but let me just give you the top
line
capitalism has always worked somebody
said commodification earlier who said
commodification okay
who said commodification there you go
okay come on a vacation that's an
important word here capitalism has
always worked by claiming things that
live outside the marketplace like
innocent forests and mountain sides and
rivers and fields and dragging them into
the market dynamic turn them turning
them into commodities that can be sold
and purchased and in that sense
surveillance capitalism emulates a sort
of centuries-old pattern of how
capitalism grows but with a very dark
twist it turns out we're kind of out of
territories to commodify Google
discovered what may be the last virgin
wood and that turns out to be our
private experience Google claimed our
private experience as free raw material
to be translated into behavioral data
these data would be collected from every
domain it began online as you all know
but it now reaches far beyond online
who's got an Alexa in their kitchen
who's got a TV that listens who's
walking down the street not only passing
the CCTV cameras which are public sector
but the tech companies have thought for
the right to be able to take our faces
from any public space without our ever
knowing forget about consent forget
about the right to combat so now these
data are being amassed they are valued
for their rich predictive signals they
are shunted into complex supply chains
of data flows they are conveyed picture
those old-fashioned conveyor belts
conveying them right into the factory
but what is this Factory
it's a computational Factory it's called
a
artificial intelligence but like any
factory it makes products in this case
it makes prediction products
what's computed our predictions of our
behavior turns out there are a lot of
businesses who have a keen interest in
knowing what we will do soon and later
first to sell is targeted ads but it
doesn't stop there there are all kinds
of reasons to know what we will do in
the future what price to sell us their
service or their product whether or not
to give us an insurance policy and at
what level of cost whether or not to
give us a mortgage or a bank loan there
are lots and lots of reasons they want
to be able to predict our behavior how
are we going to drive that you know that
can influence what our auto insurance
look like there are many many issues and
they arise in every single economic
sector all right so these prediction
products are sold to business customers
in a new kind of marketplace strictly
interested in what we will do in the
future
zoom out a tiny bit these are markets
that trade exclusively in human futures
that's what they do
surveillance capitalists are selling
certainty not to us but to business
customers based on deep deep data and
broad broad data that's about us but
that's not for us it's about us but it's
not intended to sell art to solve our
problems but to meet the goals of its
business customers all right now
what we've seen here is that we've got
markets that trade in human futures you
look at the economic imperatives that
define those markets if you're gonna
compete on predictions what's the first
thing you need you need a lot of data
you need a lot of data for good
predictions because as everybody knows
AI likes to chew up a lot of data then
it turns out competition keeps grinding
no
only do you need a lot of data you need
varieties of data let's get them out of
that out of you know off the laptop
let's get them out of the house let's
get them in the city let's get them in
the car let's get them on the maps
let's get them walking around their home
let's get their voice let's get their
posture you know are their shoulders
stoop let's get all of that let's get
their faces we like their faces because
we like to analyze the muscles in the
face there are hundreds of tiny muscles
in the face they produce gestures
effective computing analyzes those
facial gestures predicts your emotions
emotions turn out to be highly
predictive of your future behavior all
of this is very very valuable the market
capitalization of Microsoft Google
Facebook and now increasingly Amazon
depend on the revenues that throw flow
through these markets a leaked Facebook
document in 2018 revealed what's going
on in its AI hub Facebook describing its
own operation we don't get that many
glimpses into this what did it say our
AI ingests I'm using their words ingest
trillions of data points every day it
trains millions of models AI models
predictive models every week and is able
to produce six million their words not
mine I'm going to put them in air quotes
6 million predictions of human behavior
per second per second that's what's
going on in the factory okay
surveillance capitalism puts us on a
collision course with democracy they
understood that they needed scale they
understood that they needed scope in the
way they collect data ultimately they
understood that the most predictive
insights come from actually intervening
in our behavior and learning how to
nudge coax tune and herd our behavior in
the direction that satisfy their
guaranteed outcomes now this is a whole
new experimental zone I call it
economies of action and we've been lucky
enough to see some of these experiments
hiding in plain sight for example
Facebook conducted what it called
massive scale contagion experiments were
used subliminal queues on Facebook pages
to see if it could alter real-world
behavior and real-world emotion it did
this in 2012 and 2013 the results were
written up in prestigious academic
journals in both cases the researchers
emphasized two conclusions one we've
learned that we can using subliminal
cues online affect real-world behavior
and real-world emotion number two we've
learned that we can do this in ways that
are undetectable to users we can do this
by passing user awareness they never
know it's happening all right so now
here's a crash course on the collision
with democracy everything I've just said
to you about the economic imperatives of
these markets suggests that surveillance
capitalism undermines democracy from
above and from below from above these
data agglomerations
represent a new source of social
inequality is the 21st century is it not
it's the digital century is it not we
came into this century believing it was
going to be the most democratic of any
century the internet was going to
democratize knowledge instead something
unexpected has happened we have these
vast asymmetries of knowledge to an
extent that has never existed before
exemplified in a growing abyss between
what we know and what is known about us
I call this epistemic inequality
inequality of knowing inequality of what
we are able to learn they have all this
knowledge and of course more knowledge
means more power more knowledge about us
means more opportunity to control
behavior always remotely never
threatening us bodily not threatening
murder or terror not coming to drag us
off to prison if we don't agree but
through the remote digital layer through
the digital devices through the layer of
the digital that increasingly surrounds
us so now we're entering the third
decade of the 21st century with these
enormous asymmetries of knowledge and
the power that accrues to knowledge it
is on a collision course with democracy
from below because in order to get the
most refined predictions the predictions
that approximate certainty it must
interfere with human autonomy with our
agency with our ability to decide what I
do now and what I do next
where we are increasingly subject to
precognitive subliminal queues that
invade our environment and are carefully
engineered to bypass our awareness and
therefore robbed us of the right to
combat
all right what happens here is a kind of
wonderland we've entered a kind of
wonderland where things that we thought
were the case are the opposite of the
case let me give you an example we
thought these services were free but
actually these companies think that me
are free we think we're using social
media but actually social media is using
us right now 97% of Facebook's revenues
come from its online targeted
advertising markets which are a direct
result of this logic that I have just
described to you we think that we're
searching Google we've found out that
actually Google is searching us we think
that these companies have privacy
policies when in fact their privacy
policies are really surveillance
policies we think that these are
innovative companies that occasionally
make mistakes
oops Google Google is so sorry we happen
to have a microphone embedded in the
nest surveillance system and we forgot
to tell you we actually forgot to put it
in the schematics oh we're so sorry the
mistakes are the innovations finally we
have been subdued by a line of reasoning
that says if you have nothing to hide
then you should not be concerned about
any of this when the real fact is and I
know that you know this because I can
see you and I see complex educated
thoughtful individuals sitting in this
room and I know that you know that if
you have nothing to hide
you are nothing because everything that
makes you you the source of our identity
the source of our will
source of our autonomy in our urge to
self-determination these are resources
that we grow and husband within us they
are intended to be private because it is
through privacy through our own
experience of sanctuary that we grow
these inner resources and they flourish
this is the struggle from adolescence to
adulthood where myself is no longer
dependent on whether they like me or
what they say about me
but what do I think what do I believe
what do I value how do I think is the
right way to act this is what's within
us and we hide it not because we're
secretive or because we're ashamed but
because only in the sanctuary of our own
lives do these capabilities grow and
without them a democratic society is
impossible to imagine thank you
for more debates talks and interviews
subscribe today to the Institute of Arts
and ideas at IAI TV
you